Yeah right. Although all the hippie dem and all the the sort of. Drug drug culture and.
And yuppies and all of that stuff lies over there from a personally which is ten kilometers to the east
and nimbin for me has always been the sanctuary you know this.
This place of abundance and plenitude where i learned how to look after the gardens.
How to look after the horses had had to witness the weather coming over. Do all those country things and.
You know probably. Above everything how to look after myself my family. You know.
Without all the added stresses of of a full on occupational career or or. Traveling or cars or traffic or buildings or.
Made your communications and all those sort of distorting and disturbing things you know. Taking in big doses. So.
So what it is from a here is a natural. Basis for living.
Which is beautiful enough not to have to be invited by by civilization.
And that's what you say you know when you look out the window. It's what you can see out there. Well i think that.
I spent time in the city and i thought. I spent long enough there to know what it was like.
I went to two high schools there. During my high school career and you know.
Growing up there my father lives down there now it's like down there. So. I mean. Thank god.
When you've got the best of both worlds. You know you're lucky enough to sort of have. At the bit.
You know what the city can offer and what the country can offer. But given the choice i think i always choose what.
What you have up here. City's great but i think. Cities for. It just seems like such a fragile place. You know.
It's a sort of. It's a whole system of its own that looks like it's on the verge of concern. You fall into.
And i wonder if one day it will actually fall down. And all those people won't have anywhere to go. I think. Yeah.
So this is where it's at me. My pleasure. What i'd like to offer is a conclusion. To all of this is that.
I think the made and. In general interest amongst the strains. Elsewhere. Has been named a particularly.
Confrontational strange or frightening place and i think what really is important for people to understand now is that.
Is that name been easy integrating and is becoming much more.
Much more ordinary than what would people would normally think and i think that's what's important about it.
That it needn't be this unique or special or mystical or transcendent place at all which it isn't.
But just be a beautiful haven. The people to come to when they want to. You know. Absolutely yeah. The.
They've actually. And they've actually been able to blend so much.
Into mainstream media an understanding in communications that year. Of our laps now.
And i think the thing about newman as it's not. It's not going to perform that role too much in the future anymore.
Sure it's got its perma culture hamlet
and it's called her new energy systems which are very much to the logical developments but the whole. Ethical and.
Spiritual and societal. Influence which newman has had is is not so much the issue anymore.
And i don't think people should. Should have false expectations or that is. Sure. If not prefer.
If not prophetical visionary it's. There's a stereotypical image of. Of out.
Altered decadence or ultra self-indulgence alter. Ultra. Nihilism.
You know existential angst sort of floating around the ice i'm sure that's true but.
But isn't that the same everywhere. And this is not sort of nimbin just a reflection of any anywhere else.
And i mean you can walk down any place in sydney and see a marker cosmo what nimbin is you know.
Just you know been turned. So i think indians always held this. This sort of. Intriguing mysterious.
Role in a strong society since the early seventies.
And i think now it's time for people who are out there in living in in conservative.
Suburban harms to realise that that the change is going to start happening from there.
You know in humans all right but it is. It's going to sort of. Grab along in you know sort of.
Happily develop into a scene obsolescence you know. While every. Everything else just keeps on blowing up.
And i think that's important for for suburban people. For people who leave.
Out there amongst amongst millions of other people to understand it.
And that it's important to learn how to organize their lives in a more ethical and sound way. Ok..
So for the fourth of december not you know speaking with gloria. Constantine can use c. O. N. S. T. I n. E. G.'s o.
Well i'm gloria constantine. And i work at the name in news. That. I've been a name in about ten to eleven news.
I visited nimbin for two years before that. Fast now. He said to pipe her. In melbourne. Before i came up here.
So it was pretty irrelevant to get involved with a name in news which i did about. Oh between eight and nine years ago.
Distilling. Different things. Into fears and what have you. Just. Now it's much bigger. The.
That if is a train this pipe and the pipe i did before was that.
There's also similarities and that is that they're all voluntary that. You don't get paid anything.
This is just bigger. It's more involved. Why do a wide range of topics. Yeah. You use. It's.
Now let's see if i were reading it for the first time i suppose you'd get an overview
or you get an insight into what's happening around nimbin. We get lots of letters coming in. Some of them.
Criticizing different aspects of the society and. Where applies to that but.
Just different letters have from different paper that gives a good idea of what's happening and. We also. We ate.
Matou it out of other magazines that we swapped with so that the most up to date information is thought witty.
I pay of. Nimbin if you know that way we had all the information you think's important. That paper should now.
And get that in there. We want to educate people. Can you use those sources. Yeah i can do that.
I can see the source is. Wow. We've got plenty of sources is social turn to to use can't use. China action.
Coyote's ho from japan. Silver cold. Swan. The whole person and most agenda. Come via. Some of these a firm.
I've a say soft technology. Bix. Grab. News letter. And i mean told if.
Nexis garden oh you know i mean i mean we get them all and screw right. So much.
Oh my oh i should you know ask in my oh. Today it's not all mind. You. And we get quite a bit.
You get quite a bit of you know the end of month we get the magazines come in in the month place. We also get a lot of.
We seem to be on somebodies list which i wish we weren't we getting all these media release of. Beauty products and.
Pit sings in you know the stuff that we're really not interested in oh.
You know they just send all of this stuff i mean there's even a brochure sent to them out which.
You couldn't even undo the clasp. But.
I just mean i really wish they would sort of tie his off the least and save a man a you know.
Well we don't know who's put us on some list but obviously we're there and we can. The staff. We even had.
Stuff from telecom which wasn't too bad i suppose but. You know i mean. We hear from them anyway.
Time when they want their money. Now just resent being on a on a list of people they've got the impression that.
That the stuff that they're sending in these is good in that you know they haven't noticed taken off it when.
You know it just gets put seeing the unsolicited mail releases pile. And that's where it stays. Yeah.
It's a real home and i. We were sending them back at first but. Didn't they still send them out.
I mean we said we get some from. From them every week.
Different people we get stuff every week you know it's incredible. It's not much of the stuff. We can.
We can use it all. In fact very very little.
And this is now it's an australian list obviously we're not getting stuff from elsewhere. You know.
What's the sort of office in which. Use through. Topics. Well. We get lots and lots of power trade which he's great.
Really nice way of expressing yourself and apparently can't get sued if it helps the forestry. Fost problems you know.
The environment is a predominance you know you can assign ecology and you can move in with you know.
Trying to find the best ways of doing things and it seems that. Why is it doing things.
Information of the wife doing things that is not going to pollute the environment and. Send us to our destruction.
Which i think is something that is affecting everybody even if i don't talk about it very much.
He's still a sort of a depressing thought to think that you know.
The world as we know it might not be involved for for the end of allaf time when that event the future or. Issues.
Yeah this. There are very heavy deep rights. We. We just give people the opportunity to debate that. That in the paper.
I think it is. These always a tendency that people don't mistry in themselves to the actual issue rather than.
They tend to attack the person. Which he's you know. Not the best way to do things. The issue is is what's at stake.
Not whether you put somebody down oh. Make somebody feel say. It's free press.
Well it's not it's i mean we don't preach everything that comes in they some stuff that.
We would gain some stuff from from a guy. Mr praying.
Actually who went away was a god he was i would say somewhere south america.
And was sending us stuff from there i mean the sin is copious amounts of stuff that we couldn't.
We couldn't get any make any sense of. While he was in australia and when he went to south america he sent a small.
But sore. Thoughts and i know you haven't seen them for a while and i think maybe the message.
But he was attacking other people in these latest who. You know i got bit personal politics politics is about.
The local politics of this. There's lots of different cliques and groups and people.
Different ideas different i.d.'s one of the price. They knock of range from the super very cold.
To they super strike if you like. Beyond us. But within that range is what newbies.
There are quite like the most democratic market. And they can. And that. I think. And i kist stick. They work.
They walk i say and i kissed a democracy yeah. I don't know that i could put the. Two words together but.
It depends on how many am how much she can blab. Into home. You know.
Who would listen to you as to how good you doing the point politico. Political stuff. You know.
This is politics and policy exists dirty politics in these getting the message across
and the dirty politics is the law isn't xed makes it worse would. Well exploited.
Awake exploitation is exploiting the situation. But a situation can happen and lies and exaggerations. Become.
What's heard and. If you don't have an opportunity to. You know.
If you haven't got the time or the inclination to go blab blab blab and as much as what the opposition has.
Then you've sunk. Sean he can't even write. Mr jones mr jones. You know the mrs jones of him. Well that was.
That was pretty incredible. I had people come out to me in the street saying that traffic guy you know i said.
He's a bit sas. And i mean i knew that but i mean.
Strategy their policy was that you know if anybody wants to work on the name a nice thing. Come and want it.
And he was willing to do some work and so he sort of can be.
This was a time before we just as we would get in the mail box
and mail box we were saving my all for this person before we were saving any amount for us.
And he was he had great plans of doing or for the alternative press. You know tentative price it was going to be.
And he was going to be. Gavin and it was going to get a c.p. Grant of half a million dollars. I had people.
Cat in paper barely had a factory. Vented in this mall and had no sort of.
Nothing really to back him up because there was on. Investigation there was no safe pain. Around him.
Anyway then he got to me that registered the name in the news in his nine. And i mean.
You know i should have images to jesus got about i mean nobody our didn't wasn't even aware that.
You know registration had to happen even. You know what i think we're taking care of him.
He found out that it wasn't me just didn't him i just did it in his name plus a rainbow news and.
I tricked him into admitting it.
I said you know how much it cost to buy just the name you mean using you and i'm not in your life.
How much it cost to register and even use and. He said oh all. Member how much it was but one.
What if it was sixty bucks. So now i whose name did you register in. He said oh my i thought i said.
Did he lie down trick isn't it. Said you know i can't you know i done it in your and i i says well. That's business.
That's business. It's the shadows the shouters and they are prized.
So when he was holding to these nine was going to be mad from now on and that you better clear off from being used.
He's kazin and bring his case in first and then feel off because he wouldn't be taken seriously anymore. And so.
I actually. The first rainbow news that came out we were trying to sort of become financial.
By bringing out a paper each month which was going to be alternately the vent name in news and rainbow news.
For the first rainbow news that was the next one that was coming up
and it couldn't wait for the following one which would be the name. So i sort of printed something about it. In there.
But we eventually got the really news we just didn't and i'm after. And it will be it for five years.
There's also mr jones he's out there. I don't think you want to show his face.
What sort of structures that will use my. It's oval system. Oh yes it's still voluntary although we do have placings.
Some of our advertising these. Swaps for. Virtues. That enable us to go and say in a restaurant or.
Have a message of pictures or something that they're not very much i mean any.
Very small amount but that just makes a little bit of icing on the cake for us you know apart from being at the pipe
and we can do that and that's. Yeah. Hardly. But in. Stressful.
I used to be stressful it's not anymore it's working really really well right now we've got a great group working
together. The stuff that comes in even the stuff that. Skates chuy's net of the piper. So that it's.
We try and take the power out of positions. If you like.
We don't have an eighty turner sub eighty seven of this in there that. We just sort of do what we can.
And what needs to. Down. And we get the piper out and. You know some of us get better at other things.
You know certain things like you know i don't go near the computer. But other people are you know we spang.
At the computer and stuff like that. Anyway i am. Stuff that comes in we put it up on the board and. Twenty three one.
Say paypal voting for it to go and of hyper then it gets processed going to paper.
They might be stuff they that might get.
To runs into stories so you know if you put a story on it it means that you know not recommended.
Well there's a two which means that. It's a possibility if this. You know if you start for filler. Which we wind up.
Not usually. We've got so much stuff on the board you know that that could go in that.
We don't really need feelers but.
It may need to be eighty two or something may need to be down to it to make except of two going
or it might be relevant to put it in you know a lot of that might be some kind of a fruit fly trap with some cheese.
Silly put in in the winter when nobody's thinking at all about fruit flies. Yeah yeah yeah.
And of course seeing the local stuff the letters and they stuffed of. The days. There's more emphasis on that is more.
That has a higher priority than any. Reprinted stuff. And that goes in.
And this is an objection to it we try and see everything before it goes in some time and we. There is such a lag.
You know somebody is very slow to get it in
and we don't even see it before it goes you know that's only happened once and there's been a problem with that.
So i would like to be i would say in a safe make sure nobody's doing anything come down astley. In the writing.
That can get ass and them into trouble. But it's you know it's unfair on acid. Staffs put in tonight.
And we don't have a chance to process it
but we've got the spice that we've you know we've got to get it to the printer. So was right. Oh yeah sure. Yeah.
Well though some people prefer not to be applying just sort of black or black least anybody associated with the paper.
I mean. I suppose it's you know. Maybe it's my paranoia. You know. Solutions from.
Yeah yeah we've got subscriptions from live the place.
We've got enough subscriptions i would probably not pushing it as much as we could. But we even got more one.
Subscription from over say oh now two. Is alive if i v c's. And yeah we get subscriptions who know.
We've just been working on our archives and we're getting. We're getting five together. Of. Total archives.
Which he's an horrendous job. That. One of our work his name has been working on and.
He's doing a magnificent job just saw him at these papers that we lugged around from place to place
and all these boxes and boxes and boxes of paper. You know. All the offices. Well in the time not been made it. We've.
We've been under the townhome and that was a real rummy price. It's like.
I mean you wouldn't know his her wasn't an asset always very. Ganji is.
There was you know there's a floor above us and if anybody want on the floors and.
You get all the stuff coming through the sale you know it's horrible. Everything was covered in. Rot.
I mean you know he clearly i mean and him. Oh i doubt that. And i i mean me i often think you know.
I'm sure that somewhere in india there was something. Someplace worse.
But i mean it was good to be able to be there
and it was it was a start for us we didn't have any money we couldn't pay when we were in town which was very good.
And. I mean my aversion to grow up he's not sort of necessarily. If you body's problem.
And then we then we've entered a room from the community school which was really nice. Spent. That either i think.
Maybe a little bit longer. And then i went to my pace china us. Then when i came back. Well.
Picked up underneath the tomato sauce factory. Because the school needed they were. I had no way to die so they me.
And he to get ahead has the band has a tenable folds and we.
We moved in there and that was really good how he asked so i sailed it's amazing we've got the phone on while.
I was really coming up in the world. And we go to a printing press. And op shop actually.
I got this going he was an offset printing press and. Yeah we got that guy in and had that going for a while.
It was pretty pretty hard work and set up the office and. You know just. Just tried it out why and to gain.
Having a little bit of money in paying the bills and. But never anything. To pay the workers at all.
And now we've got this. We would they have asked we know. Now six she's sick she's in the time. I said. Fasten.
But sick she was we were there. And now we're in this office in town behind same's organic food shop and.
He's great it's very hot in the summer that he's very compact we've got me and when i say. Organize i sell us and.
Can have big furniture or anything and.
They frankly functions in where we are so now we're managing to make it so that it works for us. Any problems.
Structure. A secular structure. On a non hierarchical structure and yeah. I don't.
Because now we all treat each other really well actually. Fishley this group is presently. Here taking a long while.
But yeah. Talking past the padded positions. And that is that you know.
The eighty thousand sort of police pushes wide and.
On everybody else we all make decisions we have made things about things and. You know if we go to.
Going to spend more than a hundred bucks we make a decision about it and.
If we're going to make a change in the present strategy we make a decision about it. We don't sort of.
People don't sort of assume that something's going to happen and then do it and drag everybody along these.
Make decisions about it so you know what way going what you do and if you want to take part you do.
And if you don't you don't see the you know they actually. Always been. It's going manny well it's financially.
Spy and it's bills with went out to falter a fold. From leaving town of all. To come in here. But.
We've organized wise of overcoming that. You know i mean. Increase in advertising and.
Of course the advertising and mining count.
Yeah we just make sure that you know that we get enough coming in to pay the bills. That there isn't this.
And so i taking that step to actually be him financially as far as pie in paid was another matter that is nowhere near
inside. Yeah. Everybody would like a. Yeah we know it's really good.
It's good to be able to actually put your skills to some use. And.
Produce something that is really good that people can actually in the street
and say are not human use was really good at best yet you know the last six times that people have been the science of
a stream. So it must be improving.